Cette conférence est actuellement en cours d'enregistrement
Son cher rapporte salutations sur place
de Fribourg, c'est un plaisir de nous revoir
comment vas-tu, bonjour
Je suis très heureux qu'ils aient fermé à nouveau
voir et que tout le monde puisse parler
faire le point sur ceux-ci
terrible crise, nous avons dit que
nous, elle l'aidera surtout oui
Cette année aussi, principalement par téléphone portable
plus tard dans la soirée avec l'idée que nous
une conversation de notre part aussi
enregistre-nous aussi après
mettre à la disposition du public
facile à voir
Ceci est particulièrement important en temps de crise
Les amis échangent des informations sur la façon dont les choses se passent
On est amoureux de toi en France
Allemagne
et dès le début j'en aurais un autre
question de compréhension de la côte parce que je crois
Maire de Fribourg
relativement clair pour votre fonction
c'est très clair en France mais maintenant
pour nous pour ceux qui vous sont connectés
Le président a amélioré le domaine du droit
et combien de personnes vivent avec toi
donc je laisse les 28 distribués
capital-conseil conduit et nullité
Colmar et Mulhouse par exemple
aussi en haut donc le débat est plus là
environ 770 000, c'est une bonne affaire
et donc nos compétences ici en huit
Parfois il y a de la solidarité dans la rue
et mes collègues aussi maintenant
beaucoup à dire et déjà réglé
à presque deux ans de manière très intensive et
Cependant, ces derniers temps, les temps ont été plutôt difficiles
provoquer des moments assez difficiles
J'en ai un avec toi en France
regardé de notre aujourd'hui notre
Les statistiques d'aujourd'hui montrent à quel point c'est vrai
chiffres officiels puis souhaits
Demandez simplement comment vous souhaiteriez l'isolement
Donc c'était déjà là aujourd'hui
un autre quatrième pourboire signalé en 2020
cas en Allemagne 73 000
522 et en France 56 000
théoriquement beaucoup moins
mais si tu regardes les chiffres des décès
je le regarde et c'est effrayant alors
D'après ces statistiques, nous avons 4000
décès en France en Allemagne 870
et donc indépendant d'eux
Quelle ville est la plus importante ?
demande des offres d'amour quelle est la situation
dans Marl Hüls, comment est-elle toujours
Malheureusement, la situation avec toi est toujours là
de toute la France dans la situation
ce qui est très critique, nous sommes donc
Le FC Ibach serait avec le temps des gens
can can est malheureusement mort
Alors payez à partir du 1er avril le premier
Avril est le premier avril environ
400 merci beaucoup dans les raides
l'hôpital dit à Torben les maisons de retraite
ainsi que nos considérations sont approximatives
330 personnes âgées sont mortes et une
pas même les malades petit à petit
Alors oui, on en a aussi besoin à la maison
sont dans le spectateur demain un très très
Les situations critiques sont également un problème
c'est la cellule de l'hôpital
sont pleins sont surchargés et les plus gros
Le problème ce sont les endroits sur les pentes raides
murs dans les gares gares de liaison
unités de soins intensifs et c'est là que je veux être
merci
Je préférerais avoir ton aide parce que tu
Nous nous sommes disputés ensemble pour des endroits
à l'hôpital allemand de Cannes
et tu fais le premier qui a dit
je vais mieux
[Musique]
Merci beaucoup
Merci beaucoup, l'amour passe avant tout
Nous en sommes en nombre effrayant
Heureusement, Fribourg est encore plus loin
mais bien sûr, nous l'emportons avec nous
choc et regret de savoir
certaine situation est avec vous et
surtout parce qu'on est si bien sinon
travailler ensemble
Je dois avoir une amitié alors
montrer en temps de crise et c'est pourquoi
j'ai mon petit aussi
pas possible de payer
le Land de Bade-Wurtemberg
Le conseil régional de Fribourg les a
qui a été effectivement mis en œuvre
et je pense que j'ai fini par avoir 20 ans
Nous avons ensuite été gravement infectés
Le Bade-Wurtemberg a déménagé, mais c'était
un signe très important précisément parce que
alors oui, les paris sont redevenus gratuits et vous
Chaque incendie rapportait que c'était comme ça
est mauvais
tu dois l'avoir en partie les gens
un certain âge n'existe plus
on pouvait respirer parce que c'était facile
Il n'y avait pas d'appareils et je n'en ai même jamais eu
de l'hôpital militaire Hus ou de nous
avoir un chauffage de classe mondiale pour la prairie 30
plus intensément et chaque jour chaque jour
sont tombés malades à cause de - et ont été
de Colmar vers d'autres régions de
Des avions ont volé avec la France
hélicoptère également à Bordeaux
après être selon le programme
et heureusement aussi avec nos voisins
L'Allemagne en Suisse le Luxembourg et
Ce matin, j'ai reçu un email de
Je le reçois même de ma famille
je ne sais pas
déclencheur et cette famille dit un
jeune homme, il le dit à beaucoup
merci beaucoup
qui seulement après l'hélicoptère allemand
et il était à la clinique universitaire de Hajduk et
deviner
comme c'était sain oui, c'était vraiment très
joli
Merci encore, je le prends
pensé exactement à
Merci d'avoir dit merci beaucoup
mais cette banque est aussi très claire
mais aussi plus loin dans le RP jusqu'à Fribourg
dans le pays dans lequel vous avez distribué jusqu'à présent et avez
à 16h17 et retour en hélicoptère à
fourni était important, pour ainsi dire
la lutte pour les patients que le
bundle mais cela a donné lieu à de nouveaux
les patients ne sont pas d'accord avec vous et elle
Vous en avez aussi pas mal en France
il n'a pas plu ce matin
encore une fois selon notre situation doit être dans
Fribourg nous voici
Nous avons 600 huit infections
composants le matin ça fait 46 de plus
comme hier c'est toujours tous les jours ce max
L'équipe ci-dessus est différente
et nous avons aussi 19 morts
touché et chaque cas est aussi un cas
beaucoup mais bien sûr à ne pas comparer
avec la situation avec toi et c'est
À ce stade, il est très important que nous soyons là
aussi bien sur un support
mais vous bénéficiez également du soutien de
du gouvernement à Paris à propos du vôtre
les patients sont également traités tout au long
La France a vraiment volé oui oui oui
Exactement
j'ai survolé la France comme je l'ai dit
à celje bordeaux après le brutal
même pas en fonction du prix et aussi maintenant en
toute l'Allemagne selon le conseil d'administration jusqu'à
Berlin et donc personne qui nous étions
pas préparé à ce tsunami
pas en France ne tape pas Alsace
et nulle part mais je voulais aussi dire
qu'elle apprécie la situation avec nous
stabilisé en Alsace qui a cela
semaine moins de malades
sont venus mais malheureusement il y a beaucoup
de très mauvais cas
une maison huit et donc sans solidarité
pour une mobilisation de tous les toits et
ne pense pas à l'allemand
L'expert Lang était oh oui dans le Wurtemberg
donc peu de gens pourraient vivre
Alors merci beaucoup, je suis très heureux de rester
Je veux juste dire que beaucoup ont
nous a écrit et l'a soutenu
je vous ai remercié et j'ai clairement demandé cela
et bien sûr, il y a des gens qui
dis comment peux-tu avoir juste besoin de nous
nos lits pour nous mais le
Tu ne peux même pas comparer la situation
et si nous sommes dans cette situation maintenant
pas seulement parce qu'il a peur que dans le
Vous verrez exactement ça dans 20 jours
peut déterminer
alors tu pourrais laisser tomber
les gens meurent et c'est tout pour moi
Tellement choqué par Michael Utz aussi
de continuer en tant que maire, les listes ont quelque chose
vous avez signalé que nous
moyen et très motivé
Fribourg, pour ainsi dire, nous avançons
partir parce que ça a l'air si mauvais
Je dois vous parler de vos expériences négatives
Apprenez aujourd'hui, par exemple
Vous connaissez aussi notre foire
Nous y avons une clinique externe approfondie
aménagé pour accueillir aussi des personnes
pour ainsi dire, en ambulatoire 30 et test et
pour toute la région du à
accélérer
Donc nous aussi nous en sommes sortis
vos expériences aussi les négatives
des expériences plus motivantes
Presque tout peut être fait via Steam
une énorme crise pour la France
Allemagne Europe également uniquement européenne
crise à mon avis et virus -
n'aide pas maintenant, alors ça échouera
dans une certaine mesure aussi l'Europe et bien sûr
Nous préférerions le faire si c'était avec nous
être là aussi pour voir nos voisins
pause, c'est sûr que nous ne le sommes pas
juste après mais surtout nous sommes amis
et il travaille quotidiennement et aussi dans
temps de crise ensemble
C'est vraiment comme ça que je vois que ça marche
aussi comme ça aussi ça pour le
exemple, tu ne l'as plus
très fortement sensibilisé à
la situation dans les maisons de retraite et que
est absolument absolu pour nous
Nous donnons la priorité aux nôtres
il vaut mieux vraiment prévenir beaucoup de choses
nous verrons, nous avons dit que c'en était un
gros défi et je peux le faire
ce que vous savez de l'Europe et de la France et
L'amitié avec l'Allemagne est tout ce que tu as dit
souligne que j'ai aussi avec ça
maire de notre ville jumelle
mieux quand je suis en contact étroit comme ça
que nous sommes maîtres les uns des autres, du moins idéalement
ou alors vraiment personne
Réponds, je suis vraiment content
Je parle enfin à nouveau des autres
sujets sur horst fessenheim à propos de dans
Allemagne, cette amitié est terminée
pouvoir parler de culture à travers l'école
plus de crise et tu as dit
tu dois partir à 15 heures
Te voilà dans l'interview, tu as dit
Eh bien, cher Martin, je veux juste
dire que nos relations ici à
Sauver des vies dans le Haut-Rhin
oh si belle
Moi aussi j'ai ressenti cette grande solidarité
J'ai une inquiétude pour lui
clarté quelque chose de Stuttgart
reflétait l'importance que
Situation ajustée et aide-moi et
N'attendez pas et agissez enfin
mets-en un peu ici
et votre patient produit maintenant ceci
signifie le changement et la crise aujourd'hui
un tout nouveau désordre et j'espère
ça aussi nous met en pièces
et c'est pourquoi je dis ça à beaucoup de gens
Merci beaucoup pour l'alternative et
La France est à nouveau très présente
clairement également rencontré si je le souhaite
Tout va bien pour les commerçants de Fribourg
Les collègues du maire étaient également présents
et notre conseil local a ça aussi
expressément soutenu
Je pense que c'est de ça que beaucoup vivent
ces mauvais esprits et nous devons
maintenant sauve-nous tant de personnes
merci, l'amour fait que ça arrive
tu sais que cette solidarité, c'est déjà elle
vraiment, vraiment important pour nous et comment
j'ai dit que nous étions amis de l'autre côté du Rhin
donc comme on voit qu'il y en a aussi un ici
seule région pour former des images et que
C'est en Europe que je vis ma vie
beaucoup de force pour votre santé jusqu'à présent
et Thorsten, toi aussi max